[Music]
good morning uh welcome everybody i'm
julian pagini and today in this academy
course
today we're going to be looking at 12
life lessons from david king which is
white strike he has a slightly strange
title actually david hume very famous
18th century philosopher
a real sort of figurehead of the
enlightenment
fetid in paris well known all over
europe one of the best known writers of
his time
and today absolutely one of the top
ranked historical philosophers you may
know that there was a survey done uh not
so long ago of a lot of academics in
britain and america asking them
a lot of questions about their
philosophical positions but they threw
in one question which is which
non-living philosopher do you most
identify with and top of the list by a
comfortable margin actually was
david hume beating out such people as
aristotle plato
kant
so he's kind of the philosopher's
philosopher
but actually outside of academia he's
not really that well known i if he used
to stop the average person in the street
and say what do you know about david
hume i imagine they would know very
little they may not even know the name
and even people who studied him at
university perhaps you know
he's not really known as a practical
philosopher
he's most famous for his ideas about the
operations of the mind so things about
ideas and impressions
uh which we may or may not mention later
his theories of causation of course are
also very well known
um his writings on religion are well
known it comes for ethics uh his his
ethical writings are
well known for his ideas about what the
basis of morality is but not for any
sort of practical ethical advice on
issues so he's really not really as a
practical philosopher life lessons it
would seem very odd to be looking at
david hume
but i think there's actually quite a lot
we can learn from him and i think the
reason why we miss it
is of two things that we kind of neglect
one
is that he actually wrote a great deal
which is not read at all today in
academic philosophy departments or
taught on courses of course a big chunk
of that of his history is in his day he
actually became famous as a historian
before he did as a philosopher his six
volume history of england was
widely praised and you know it was was
meant to be the the greatest history
written to date of england but also he
wrote a large number of essays on
practical issues political issues
topical issues
and these essays have kind of slipped
into the background they're they're put
they are available
in fact ever pretty much everything he
wrote apart from his letters and
correspondence is available online at a
wonderful website hume texts online but
they're not really studied
but the other thing is that the way in
which we approach philosophy
these days is both sort of a historical
we might say a biographical we don't
really take much interest in the lives
of the philosophers themselves
we look at their ideas and we take their
ideas to
be
freestanding things that we can examine
on their own merits
and yeah the the life and times are
almost irrelevant now i think with hume
if you look at his work and his life
together i think you get a different
kind of picture and of course we know
quite a lot about his life they've been
mosner wrote the
definitive early definitive kind of
biography of him
there's been some other ones since
and there's quite a lot of
correspondence that survives from hume's
time as well so in his letters we find
out quite a lot about what he was
thinking and what he was saying
so what i want to kind of convince you
of really is that actually hume is a
practical philosopher as well as an
interesting theoretical one and there
are very interesting lessons we can
learn from him
and i've just selected 12
life lessons this is a nice round number
here's the first one
be stoical
with a small s
but don't be a stoic
and i rather like this one
because i don't deliberately want to be
provocative but the recently has been
real revival in stoicism a lot of books
published about it
kind of uh
sometimes referred to as the new
stoicism a lot of people saying that you
know in the stoics we have a kind of a
blueprint for how to live
and many books have been written with
that kind of subtext or not even subtext
as an explicit
claim
and
a lot of it sounds wonderful yeah it
always sounds very persuasive lots of
very memorable pithy quotes you get from
the stoics uh telling us things like how
we should not become too attached to
things that are beyond our control not
worry about things that we can't change
focus on what we
can change and so forth and a lot of
that sounds like a very very uh good
sense but actually i think at the end of
the day
uh i don't i'm not persuaded any of us
should be stoics and i don't think
hume was a stoic either
although hume would agree with a lot of
those kind of things you hear repeated
as being good stoic wisdom
but he wasn't a stoke himself so what do
we know about this well this is
interesting again because as a young man
he was was very earnest and and very
keen
to to get on with things and study and
become a man of letters as he put it
he was born in the early 18th century
born actually in edinburgh but he grew
up in a place called churnside near the
scottish borders
nine worlds was the family estate his
family were not rich by the standards of
the middle classes of the time but of
course by the standards of the ninety
percent of the population of course they
were they had their own houses in two
different places
uh cooks and things like this and it was
a very isolated place chancellor he grew
up there he went to university i think
it was been about 12 when he went to
university this was very very normal at
the time a very strange kind of thing
the universities were at the time he
didn't graduate but again that was
completely normal as well because in
order to graduate uh but
when you graduated the tutor basically
got some kind of fee and only certain
tutors were quite
able to get that so a lot of the time
people didn't bother and he wasn't
really that impressed by his university
days actually and concluded that um
there's nothing that you can learn from
a professor which you couldn't pick up
from a book
and that was perhaps something which
still remains true today so maybe you
should stop listening now and just read
a book instead but anyway he did that he
came back and then he set himself to
work very seriously he was very earnest
he was very very interested in the
stoics
and he read them very seriously but he
ultimately concluded that
the stoics weren't for him they weren't
right and why was that well
here's a key quote i think
hume puts things so well if you read him
initially it can sometimes be a bit
off-putting he in his 18th century prose
has a lot of kind of long sentences
slightly strange spellings etc etc if
you sort of get into the rhythm of it
he's actually a wonderful writer great
stylist and very very clear
and here's his kind of the bottom line
about why you shouldn't be a stoic with
a capital s philosophers have
endeavoured to render happiness entirely
independent of everything external that
degree of perfection is impossible to be
attained now that really is the hard
message of stoicism which i think a lot
of modern advocates kind of gloss over
if there's anybody in the room who's a
modern stoic as it were you can feel
free to argue with me later i know that
people who say this simply not true the
stoics did think that things like our
relationships could be of value even
money pleasure all the things that we
normally take pleasure in the stoics did
think they could be of value but they
weren't of the highest value and we had
to be careful about how we related to
them it's how we related to them that
mattered but actually i think if you
look at what the stoics actually said
i think that's making it sound a bit
more palatable than it really is on
their theory of value the only thing
that really mattered was our intellect
it was logos and reason and that was the
only thing within our control and
everything else was was relegated and
they called them preferred indifference
in the sense that it was okay to take a
certain amount of pleasure of them if
they came along or a part of your life
but you mustn't get attached to them and
you mustn't see them have been great
importance and that's why you've got
these fairly sort of hard
passages which are there in black and
white such as
i always forget which which stoic said
what but you know that when you kiss
your wife and you kiss your children you
should remind yourself that they're just
flesh and blood and they will die so
that you are not too upset when they do
die so it's this kind of thing of making
yourself invulnerable to things that are
not in your control as being the key to
happiness and and as human said here
therefore rendering happiness entirely
independent of everything external
now you can see why you would want to
make your happiness independent of
everything external wouldn't that be
wonderful that would mean your happiness
you'd be invulnerable essentially
nothing that happened to you
could affect your happiness
uh your happiness would only be affected
by what was internal to you your own
ways of thinking and so forth so it's a
very very attractive option
but human says here the degree of
perfection is impossible to be attained
because you know that's just not a human
life frankly and if you look at how the
stoics actually lived you find that they
really didn't live up to what they're
advocating here anyway most of the time
they did value things external to them
um a few of them had quite a bit of
money for a start
now
here's another question which i think
takes this a little bit further makes it
a little bit clearer
the real idea of becoming a stoic with a
capital s
is
essentially to stop extinguish or to
dampen down those emotions and passions
which make us attached to things that
are beyond our control right
now here's what hume says those refined
reflections which philosophy suggests to
us
is that commonly they cannot diminish or
extinguish our vicious passions without
diminishing or extinguishing such as our
virtuous and rendering the mind totally
indifferent and unactive
so what he was really suggesting here
is that it's kind of not possible just
like selectively switch off the emotions
which lead us to unhappiness and
distress etc without the same time
switching off all those other emotions
which give us the joys in life so if you
go back to relationships you know you
can't turn off
the emotions which are going to make you
distraught and heartbroken if those
close to you die
without also switching off precisely
those emotions which make it such a
delight to be with them
when they're alive so in that first
quote
he says that that degree of perfection
is impossible to be attained i think
really the conclusion he's also got
is that it it's not desirable to attain
it you wouldn't want to become the kind
of person that the stoics claim we
should be
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you